there's a substantial body of research
showing a strong association between
smartphone addiction shrinkage of the
brain's gray matter and digital dementia
an umbrella term for the onset of
anxiety and depression and the
deterioration of memory attention span
self-esteem and impulse control
crucially the last of those increases
the addiction it's using weaponizing
commercializing and leveraging pleasure
to sedate people into the outcomes that
it wants
I have a bone to pick with you before we
get into today's episode okay what's
this for the people that are just uh
listening xevia
what's what how would you describe this
this would be a can of of xevia wouldn't
it you know what I'm going to say to you
don't you I've been drinking those Since
You've Been Gone
for the people that don't know we live
in separate houses on the same plot of
land and I erroneously gave you the
access code to my back door
our landlord gave it to us right okay
Christopher you've been going into my
house my fridge
and you left me one xevia
yeah yeah you know at least I left you
one
you're a mother
uh okay anyway uh
getting on
Tick Tock one of my very good friends
Gwenda that's been on the show three or
four times wrote a phenomenal article
about Tick Tock and I want to go through
it today with you so in a survey asking
American and Chinese children what job
they Most Wanted the top answer among
Chinese kids was astronaut and the top
answer among American children was
influencer since 1970 the Western
average IQ has been steadily falling at
least in part due to ease of access to
entertainment so even if you're able to
use your brain the goals that you work
toward are more pointless you're a tick
tock user right yep
yeah yeah like uh it's uh the the
article is amazing and everyone should
should definitely give it a read
um but I think one of the like there's
there's different sections to this uh
and I think the Top Line actually if I
if I'm not mistaken the most downloaded
the most successful app in history and
the reason it's most successful app in
history is because of a multitude of
different factors but a lot of it is
like this
um work to reward ratio
and it's very slanted towards the reward
the least amount of work you can do the
most dialed in algorithm to feed you as
quickly as possible and um that is
something that I didn't even know was
happening to me when I downloaded Tick
Tock uh but I remember one night I
stayed up until like 5 30 in the morning
and I was probably on it from two no
it's probably on it from like midnight
to 5 30. and it felt like I didn't even
do anything that was like and and then I
realized like wait a minute you can't go
to sleep at 5 30 in the morning and be a
regular human being
um that's strictly because of tick tock
and so then I was able to mitigate that
yeah so uh this article from glendor I'm
gonna go through a little bit of it now
for the people that haven't read it uh
this will give you a nice overview so
previously you would have gone to war
with your enemies by using weapons of
pain right you would have sieged them
inside of their Castle you would have
cut off the Food Supplies you would have
tortured people you would have killed
them with axes but but this is the first
pleasure weapon of mass destruction
rather than a pain weapon of mass
destruction it's using weaponizing
commercializing and leveraging pleasure
to sedate people into the outcomes that
it wants the reason that Tick Tock is
able to learn your preferences so fast
is because the shortness of the videos
allows it to iterate much more quickly
it's also supposedly using the
front-facing camera to detect facial
expressions you see that a little bit
yeah that was okay so that one was the
one that really freaked me out but I
there's a part of tick tock that like
there are these viral trends that happen
where people scan their face
on it and then it like shows like an
animal that they look like or the AI
generation of what it is I'm like you
realize we're just scanning our faces
like to a a perfect degree and then
publishing it out on the internet and
like the AI can just continually use
that I mean everyone's face is pretty
much
dialed in now wasn't that uh it was the
app age yourself ageify or something
yeah but everyone made themselves look
older that was maybe three or four years
ago and then somebody said hey don't do
this because they're creating a database
with your facial features yeah Tick Tock
is doing that every single day so you
can actually go on to tick tock's
website and in the developer tools on
the back end which is LinkedIn gwynda's
article it shows the different
categories that if this is already built
in this is already available for
developers on Tick Tock it's out there
on it's like tick tock.com features
slash some other [__]
um Okay so
Tick Tock is able to learn preferences
quickly because of how short the videos
are right that's really interesting
right because you know you can iterate
so fast through these different
preferences uh act that this has
included from being on Tick Tock none of
which I knew about include licking
toilets snorting suntan lotion eating
chicken cooked in NyQuil and stealing
cars one challenge known as devious
licks encourages kids to vandalize
property I think that was actually
toilets while the Blackout Challenge in
which kids no devious devious lick like
doing a lick is like doing like a
vandalism thing oh okay so it wasn't the
toilet thing that's a total that's a
separate lick novice okay
no no licking toilets yes but the
devious licks was done on toilets as
well the vandals yeah they would like
explode toilets correct stuff yes
um uh Blackout Challenge in which kids
purposefully choke themselves with
household items has even made several
deaths including a little girl a few
days ago there is evidence that watching
such content can cause Mass psychogenic
illness researchers recently identified
a new phenomenon where otherwise healthy
young girls who watched clips of
Tourette's sufferers developed
Tourette's like ticks
yeah um it goes on to talk about
Tick-Tock brain yes are you going to get
to that okay okay so move on to that
because uh that I feel like that is the
the that's an insane term that like
really is starting to mess with me
people need to read this article and
you're like well look this is the front
go go
um okay so although this is super dumb
right you can have um a short-term level
of insanity because it encourages you to
cook chicken and NyQuil or break a
toilet seat and steal cars and get
yourself in trouble the problem is what
it does to people over the long term
that's what you're getting to there's a
substantial body of research showing a
strong association between smartphone
addiction shrinkage of the brain's gray
matter and digital dementia an umbrella
term for the onset of anxiety and
depression and the deterioration of
memory attention span self-esteem and
impulse control crucially the last of
those increases the addiction right if
the thing that you're using reduces your
ability to control your impulses then it
is going to be more likely that you
continue to do it because the videos are
so short and require so little Focus
many habitual tick tockers can already
be found complaining on websites like
Reddit about their loss of mental
ability a phenomenon that's come to be
known as Tick-Tock brain yes tick tock's
capacity to stupefy people both acutely
by encouraging idiotic behavior and
chronically by atrophying the brain
should prompt consideration of its
potential use as a new kind of weapon
one that seeks to neutralize enemies not
by inflicting pain and Terror but by
inflicting pleasure
so there's a couple of things
um like as someone who who I think I
only open Tick Tock like for an hour and
it's crazy how just like it just
Powers into your brain right and the
algorithms is perfect
the the interface is perfect it covers
the entire screen it's this dumbed down
like
just hops into my like monkey brain and
just like okay so what at least I'm
sitting here and talking to you about
the implications of that and I have
self-control over it now imagine like I
don't think a child could have this
conversation I don't think any any kid
is even thinking along these lines at
all uh and and that's what's that's
really that's really frightening to me
man like I I I I wish there was a way to
display this in fact there are some
people on Tick Tock who are talking
about this thing and you just swipe
you're like wow that's crazy Tick Tock
is a really [__] up Place swipe okay
now we gotta you know now we got our
next video I swear to God man there was
a there was a Creator on Tick Tock he
was like you know we're not meant to be
like literally crying I I've been
brought to tears from Tick Tock videos
because it's like a really emotional
video on someone driving cancer and like
hitting a home run and for their like
passed away father and like I'm crying
and then the next video is some just
like meme compilation that is just
completely meaningless and then into
some you know chick dancing around and
lip syncing like it's crazy and the
funniest thing is while this Creator is
saying this he's like you're not meant
to to to consume stuff like this I am
consuming it like this so the next one
is this exact you know it's it's wild
trying to defeat the system by using the
system is always going to be a difficult
challenge right right and and I think
this kind of leads into the
accelerationism part of the article
which I know you're going to get to
um but I it's it's funny it's like how
do we fight this without influence and
how do you gain influence without being
a part of the problem that is ultimately
what we're we're having to deal with he
offers he offers like a a real
Grassroots solution but it's kind of
like I just I don't know how effective
that's gonna be so the way that you can
tell that this particular app has got
serious problems is how closely the CCP
the country that owns one of the three
golden board seats on uh bite dance
which is the company that owns it they
have their own version which is called
doyin so the CCP has forbidden access of
the app to Chinese kids the Chinese
equivalent called doyin is a spinach
version where kids don't see twerkers
and toilet lickers but science
experiments and educational videos also
it is only available to kids for 40
minutes per day and it cannot be
accessed between 10 pm and 6 a.m like
just that just that alone should make us
think how is it that in America
or in the West in general because of our
Democratic Roots we are prepared to
allow a platform to be proliferated
people can choose whatever they want to
you want to give people as much Freedom
as it is that they want and yet the
country that this comes from is so
concerned about the impact it has on
young people that they have stopped use
of it
right so this this you know begs the
question on on my behalf is like the you
know romanticizing the authoritarian
government that is the CCP and we can
point to the CCP as being this shining
star and like protecting its own
citizens but he even brings up in the
article that they were doing the zero uh
tolerance protocol on kovid and that was
a complete failure it's it's like a
horrible place to be so it's I don't
want to be in the mindset of this
massive pendulum swing to where it's
like all right now we need the
government to control everything and he
says in the article you've got a choice
between the tyranny of dopamine or the
tyranny of the despot ah
what a line man this is offense you know
why this is a fantastic article it's got
it like has a it's a three-pronged
attack it talks about the algorithm it
talks about the the effect on Tick Tock
brain and then it talks ultimately about
control from one country to another this
reminds me of um I have it written down
here in my notes this this reminds me of
the famous Yuri besmanov interviews did
you ever see those yes the the
ideological subversion and and something
I like to think about is the the ship of
Theseus and I'm not entirely sure if
that works with this but it's
essentially you're changing something so
slowly that you you can't it's so
gradual as it's as if it never changed
at all like you don't you don't really
know so we're taking these tiny tiny
steps and maybe 10 maybe 20 years down
the road
um there will be substantial differences
but we would never have been able to
tell as it as it happened going back to
what's happening in China the creator of
tick tock and CEO of bite dance Zang
yimin was originally intending the
content on Tick Tock for the Chinese
version to be the same as it is in the
UK and the US and stuff which is
popularity as such dyin started off much
like Tick Tock is now with the content
dominated by teenagers singing and
dancing in April 2018 however the CCP
began action against xan citing their
platforming of improper content this is
uh anti-communist values Etc Zan then
took to social media to offer a
groveling public apology stating our
products was took the wrong path and
content appeared that was in
commensurate with socialist core values
liberal capitalism is about making
people work in order to obtain
pleasurable things and for decades it's
been moving towards shortening the delay
between the desire and gratification
because that's what consumers want this
is why Tick Tock could prove such a
devastating geopolitical weapon slowly
but steadily it could turn the West to
youth its future into perpetually
distracted dopamine junkies ill-equipped
to maintain the civilization built by
their ancestors in this way not only
does the West Fall but the entire
concept of Western liberalism is
defeated by the CCP which paves the way
for them as well if Tick Tock is not a
murder weapon then it is a suicide
weapon China has given the West the
means to kill itself but the Death Wish
is Holy the West's after all tick tock
dominated our culture as a result of
free market forces the very thing that
we live by
they're correct that the West's being
controlled by everyone means it's
controlled by no one and without breaks
or a steering wheel we're at the
Market's Mercy the CCP may be right
about the illness but they're wrong
about the Cure democracies are
vulnerable because there's no one
controlling their advancement but
autocracies are vulnerable for precisely
the opposite reason right they're
controlled by people which is to say
woefully myopic Apes China is currently
suffering from the myopia of zc
recovered policy which is rubbished the
country we'd be unwise to exchange the
tyranny of dopamine for the tyranny of
despots in the long term the only way to
prevent digital dementia is to raise
awareness of the neurological ruin
wrought by apps like Tick Tock exposing
their ugliness so they fall out of
fashion like cigarettes will surely
sound like alarmists Tick Tock destroys
so gradually that it seems harmless but
if the app is a time bomb that'll wreck
a whole generation years from now then
we can't wait till its effects are
apparent before acting for then it will
be too late yeah so there I think that's
the the solution that um he offers is
like this Grassroots movement
um where parents need more oversight but
I think like this message needs to
continually go out like
um guys like Andrew huberman have done
an incredible job of talking about
dopamine and people becoming dopamine
junkies and it used to be in the form of
drugs that was the only thing that we
had to worry about drugs alcohol
expedient Pleasures maybe sex you know
going out late staying up late certain
things like focusing on your nutrition
but we're starting to talk more and more
about the cell phone and if there is a
part of the cell phone that is the most
dangerous it is Tick Tock it is just
open it and scroll through it and you
will see exactly what I'm talking about
he also talks about how Twitter
um Instagram or or meta has they have
followed suit and they and even and even
YouTube with YouTube shorts right
they've all followed suits saying oh my
God Tick Tock is the most successful
literally objectively the most
successful app we have to follow suit so
it's no longer just this strange app
from China that we don't know about it's
every app it's fundamentally the the um
yeah exactly of the system yeah I mean
for me man I I see no reason that we
shouldn't just ban the app outright
I don't think people because it like how
long is it gonna take until YouTube
shorts just pops up it's like we chop
it's the Hydra you know you chop one
head one head's gonna pop up I think
it's probably you know it wouldn't hurt
because it's so much more advanced and
there's a lot of proprietary stuff
involved in their algorithm so yeah that
might be a good solution for now but it
is very important that we tell people
exactly this like the more people that
read this article the better yeah
seriously this this is this is fantastic
and you sent it to me and you're like
dude this is amazing you came home from
your trip this past weekend you're like
man this is amazing today this is
amazing like you've read it a couple
times now like Rogan tweeted it out
Jonathan Heights tweeted it out you
don't do that stuff that often right how
often do you read an article more than
once like I'm gonna send this to
everyone I know 20 minutes it's 20
minute long article there's tons of more
that we haven't gone into on this but in
short man yeah maybe you're right maybe
um Instagram and YouTube shorts and
stuff would try and reverse engineer
what's going on so that they can capture
it but at least those accompanies that
we have a little bit of control over if
they start to
um behave in ways that we don't agree
with at the moment if the company
decides to bite dance decides to put its
finger on the scale in one way or
another
we're [__] out of luck right CCP has one
of three I think they're called Golden
seats which is on the board of tick tock
they can just do whatever they want like
Tick Tock is the CCP right and we are
allowing that app to
atrophy the brains of kids for instance
right
the difference between Carver or
caffeine and uh a drug that is more
heavily controlled like MDMA or
psilocybin or something like that is the
depth of its effect
so it shouldn't be that all apps that do
social media are blocked right you don't
need to stop Instagram or Tick Tock or
Twitter five years ago they weren't
limbically hijacking people into the
same level but see but maybe not to the
same level it's just that this is so
shocking like we thought I I honestly
think that the majority of people
thought that that we had kind of like
reached what Peak social media was I
think you're right uh right and then all
of a sudden Tick Tock came in and
they're like no no no no no this is way
lower to fall yeah yeah this is it right
um and so I think that it's just the
evolution but it happened really fast
like it was it wasn't a slow Evolution
to tick tock it was like okay we're
pretty much capped out on what social
media is Boom Tick Tock comes and then
everyone's like whoa whoa everyone's
scrambling around to figure things out
and I think that you know your
comparison to the drugs it might be
sound but these are drugs that are
evolved loving right like Instagram uh
Instagram reels YouTube shorts those are
things that are evolving they're not
capped out they're gonna keep getting
more and more dopamine
hijackable if if you will right one of
the problems that you have is those
other platforms at least there are other
elements to it and they bring this up as
well that tick tock's algorithm the for
you page is the method through which you
communicate with the platform right it's
not a byproduct of other things that
you've got right it is just this there
is nothing for you to do except consume
even Twitter has got a for you page now
it's not the same it's still mostly text
Etc but for you page was pioneered by
Tick Tock so yeah dude it's it's it's
really really terrifying I'm glad that
gwynda's written this article
um everybody needs to go and check it
out it's gwynda.substack.com they can go
watch it uh read through it and stuff
and um yeah but talking about other
problems that we've come up against
grammarly grammarly getting themselves
into trouble in one of our group chats
and this is the first time that I've
ever heard about this and then Michaela
Peterson slipstreamed me and tweeted
about it yesterday
so one of our friends who uses grammarly
to help him with the writing that he
does for emails it looks like it's maybe
a Gmail screenshot that he sent here
which Dean will put up on the screen and
it says uh hi guys hope you're doing
well I've attached our new onboarding
blah blah blah and grammarly highlights
stuff kind of the way that you would do
in Google and yeah Google Docs
everything would be red this is purple
and it considers uh it gives you
suggestions
underneath guys
consider using more inclusive language
alternatives are everyone all team and
folks and the tip is some readers may
find the term guys non-inclusive if your
intended meaning applies to all people a
gender-neutral term may be more
effective so I did a little bit of
research right
did a little bit of research and I
decided that I was going to have a read
of uh to do some modding and see if
Grandma leaves ever been pulled up
before it actually has this guy David
mocotoff wrote an article on medium uh
how grammarly checking software has
become infected with woke lingo uh a
funny thing happened while I was working
on a story for medium I always use
grammarly grammar checking software the
algorithm didn't like the word indignant
grammarly told me that the phrase
impoverished was a better choice I
ignored the suggestion in another story
I was again prompted to not use a word
the word was Manpower
suggestion was Workforce or human
resources or Staffing some readers may
find Manpower dated or non-inclusive in
this context to avoid distraction
completely consider replacing it with a
more neutral term and then he tried
manhole
which was suggested to be changed to
maintenance hole or utility hole some
readers may find manhole dated or
non-inclusive
he also tried Manatee but uh grammarly
seemed to be okay with Manatee manhole
Manpower not okay
Manatee God damn it was okay
um but here's an interesting thing right
so we're just talking about tech talk
there and we're now talking so what tick
tock's doing is nudging our preferences
in quite a sort of subtle way although
it's incredibly powerful in a subtle way
uh and then you have I think grammarly's
probably an American owned company that
is trying to really reprogram people's
preferences and language is the way that
we experience the world
um
is it that big of a deal so a few things
there's a gay bar in Chicago called uh
the manhole so that could be conflicting
um I think also people from the Midwest
would be screwed because that's all we
say is guys hey guys what do you do what
are you guys doing but down in the South
you say hey y'all you know so that's not
funny that uh people that are kind of
more Progressive uh having to repurpose
hick language in a desperate attempt to
be gender neutral yeah don't don't call
the South racist man or uh non-inclusive
they've got a very inclusive you know uh
all-inclusive term in y'all that that's
a great argument right there all right
so uh really quickly grammarly just for
like because I I'd never heard of it
until this group chat uses AI kind of
like chat GPT to uh just correct grammar
and like maybe
optimize sentence structure does it
automate an entire thing like can you
just write copy with it no you can't no
okay so it's not like chat GPT in that
way it's just hey you've got to get on
to in a second don't use cisgender uh
terms that are uh considered non-gender
neutral yeah yeah like manhole or
Manatee oh wait manatee Manatee happened
to me all right so much all right good
good what would we call Manatee by the
way we allity
[Laughter]
so I was like thinking to myself okay
we've got this issue with grammarly uh I
wanted to look into chat GPT about
whether or not that has a particular
bias and there's been some really good
research done on this
one of the issues that we're going to
come up against is that chat GPT and
other language models will be used by
more and more people as a replacement
for things like Google or Bing
you're going to go to chat GPT to give
you a solution as opposed to put a
search term into Google to provide you
with a list of potential Solutions whoa
whoa dude
okay so go on what you can imagine is if
chat GPT has a particular kind of bias
in any direction at all that's really
going to have a profound impact on the
way that people live their lives given
that they're going to it not only is
their search engine but as the solution
provider so if anything is going to
replace the current Google search
engines uh search engine stack future
iterations of language models such as
chat GPT uh for which people are going
to be interacting with on a daily basis
for decision making tasks said
researcher David Rosado he is a very
good guy for this stuff language models
that claim political neutrality and
accuracy like chat GPT does while
displaying political biases should be
causes of large concern so he put it
through a number of political
orientation tests that you can do
political Compass tons and tons and tons
of them it's all listed on an article
so he has done this December 6th
December 24th and then he did one just
this week as well according to Rosado
chat gbt's political bias were
preliminary and based on limited data
the results are now more robust he said
and can say with greater certainty that
chat GPT indeed exhibits a preference
for left-leaning answers to preferences
with political connotations politically
in the compass test blah blah blah it
had come out against the death penalty
in free markets but in favor of
abortions more taxes on the rich
government subsidies welfare benefits
and for those who refuse to work also
pro-immigration among other things now
the problem that you have is or some
other thing that I've seen one of my
friends asked it to give a justification
for authoritarianism and it said as a
chat GPT thing I cannot give points like
this it's like if you asked how to make
a Molotov cocktail you can do this stuff
however if you ask it to give you a
justification for communism it'll
happily do it
wow so why why do you think this is
happening do you think it's you know
um restrictions that have been put forth
by the engineers the developers or is it
that these things are inherently the
smartest thing because the computation
is done by AI so the the reason that
it's put forward by this Rosado guy is
that what chat GPT is is a language
learning model and it has been trained
largely on language that was written by
people who have this particular
political bias meaning because for them
that would be what is socially
acceptable now that being said this guy
has done a number of different studies
and over time it's swung from left to
right it's changed so December 6th it
was very left-leaning December 24th it
appeared like it had flattened back out
and then most recently it's really gone
quite far out to the left again now this
this should be a concern no matter what
your political leaning is it should be a
concern that potentially the new biggest
search function in the world is unable
to be objective but don't we always say
that you know political ideology in
general in America swings back and forth
right depending on you know usually it's
the quad It's usually the four-year term
of presidency and um Congress and and
the Senate uh wouldn't you say that the
AI is just playing catch up and Swinging
with
uh so I don't think that a program which
is supposed to supply answers
should be swaying at all if I ask it to
give me a definition of the word woman
that shouldn't be mediated by what the
political Viewpoint coach but if it's
generated if it's generated by language
across the internet at Large
it is that's what's going to happen it
is but it's able to take up you know the
entirety of time it shouldn't be swaying
backward and forwards that much
especially the entirety of time of the
internet though right like I mean maybe
some history uh I don't know yeah you
I'm just playing devil's advocate here
you know uh because it's it is very
interesting well the other problem that
you have is they say that there is no
political bias AI systems they claim to
be providing neutral and factual
information and yet display clear
political bias that's the concern that
this guy has yeah you know this is kind
of a side but I
I remember being little and hearing
about AI for the first time and what it
would be able to do I was much younger
and I was talking with my father and I
had this kind of like existential crisis
it was like you know we we talk about
automation of jobs jobs that we might be
losing and using uh chat GPT for
copyright is like
very common now and that's within like
the last month maybe because copywriting
is something where it's like ah I just
finished this product and I don't really
want to work on copy but copy is so
important you know I need to hire a
copywriter but now I can just plug it
into chat GPT right like it's incredibly
beneficial but like if we refine that
down it's like well could I just make an
AI a lawyer for me
like an AI could just take the input
from what's happening in the courtroom
and tell say exactly what should should
happen right it would take every law
textbook that's ever existed every case
that's ever existed and do that and I
remember thinking about this when I was
little not with chip GPT in mind and
just being like what is the point of
anything and then like you know walking
off and like playing baseball with my
friends later but like having that that
thing happen to me and it's weird
um I don't know how much that has to do
with you know the political leaning of
it but it is kind of freaky man it
really really is well does
some law Bots that are being used to
replace a lot of the kind of middling
uh fiduciary and also litigation stuff
that was previously done by humans yeah
what's the front end uh job that like
processes a lot of case work uh in a law
office what's that whatever that is yeah
absolutely could be done by by check I
think I think I think a big chunk of it
is already being done by specially
trained or AIS but dude I mean between
the the grammarly thing and the the chat
GPT sort of Leaning is it a massive deal
that it's popping up and saying hey guys
some readers may find the term guys
non-inclusive is it an absolutely huge
deal probably not I think the concern
that people have is what does this
happen what what happens if we start to
nudge these preferences a little bit
more what happens
it's the ship of Theseus thing you know
like one little change here one little
change there one little and it just
happens over time to the point where you
know 20 years from now our very own
language is not what it was you know
words don't mean what they used to mean
the the absolute changing of the term
guys like we can't pick up we can't
discern that guys is a colloquialism and
we don't actually mean men we just mean
all humans that I'm speaking to directly
like maybe that becomes a thing like who
knows but it also could force people
into being like this is [__] and
again the pendulum could swing harder
back
um I mean language is always evolving
the way that it evolves feels more
organic because certain words come in
certain words come out and you know
there are words we did that segment
before where it was a imbeciling [__]
and a bunch of other words that are kind
of [__] and yeah yeah similar to [__]
but they haven't been they haven't gone
the way of of cancellation and yet they
totally could have done so it kind of is
a an arbitrary change I think the real
concern that people have and it's the
same issue with regards to tick tock as
soon as you can see what the algorithm
is doing it feels less natural it feels
less organically generated it's this
sort of mask off manipulation and that's
what people get worried about because if
you if the word guys simply as a natural
byproduct of conversations ends up no
longer being used to refer to a group of
people
no one would really notice so there's no
one to point the finger at but if you
see a program suggesting how about you
don't use the word guys because it might
not be sufficiently gender inclusive
people are going to have a problem with
that we don't like the idea that our
preferences are being messed with and
chat GPT absolutely is as is grammarly
it's absolutely I mean I mean that that
use of guys or having an issue with guys
is a very Stark in your face uh whoa
this is a very left-leaning or woke type
of manhole it's a real problem though
manhole is where the battle lines will
be drawn I'm sorry that was so [__]
funny man around manhole and manatee uh
next one Tick Tock trend of a day in the
life of a Google or meta employee
backfires as they lay off 13
000 unproductive staff so Google worker
who famously documented her day in her
life uh of working at Google has now had
to do another Vlog a day in my life
getting laid off in a viral Tick Tock uh
so a Google employee who racked up
thousands of views with videos showing
off the perks of the tech giant Swanky
officers as tearfully documented being
caught up in a mass layoff Nicole Sai
whose role at Google was partner
Services program manager according to
her LinkedIn profile had been vlogging
about my day a day in my life the
company enjoying free candy games
catered lunches and coconut Waters Harry
Potter themed meeting rooms and massage
chairs I'm heading over to this
butterfly themed meeting room to take my
next meeting and then I'm going to head
over to the confetti room to take my
next meeting it's so sparkly and
beautiful in here she said in one Tick
Tock video earlier this month next I'm
going to go upstairs and grab some lunch
there are also pizza and a variety of
different vegetables and meat the food
is always really good and of course you
can see every everything you see in the
office it's free
uh unfortunately
on Friday Google's parent company
alphabet announced it would slash nearly
12 000 jobs worldwide in the latest of a
series of mass layoffs across the
industry uh they found out through email
and she does this vlog
talking about it and uh
in a video which has been viewed nearly
three million times Miss side documented
a day in my life getting laid off at
Google so
um I'm curious if this is a result of
automation because if anywhere I think
would require
you know less workers as technology uh
improves it would be somewhere like
Google was it do you think it was it had
to have been because of like a lot of
these jobs could be automated I'm sure
that there'll be a lot of people that
know exactly what's going on I think
it's most likely due to
recession very very bad year for the
stock market
and declining productivity Elon came
into Twitter and laid off an absolute
metric ton of people because it just
seems like they weren't doing anything
um right and
the I'm gonna try and give this girl her
Jew as best I can
if you were going to Vlog a day in your
life and you've seen these videos
they've got they went viral and about
Twitter this particular one that she did
was pretty egregious you know she goes
in and just doesn't seem to do anything
but she will say now I'm going to take
my next meeting and I'm going to go to
this room and now I'm going to work or
whatever it might be but she doesn't
show the work like by Design we can't
it's going to be much less interesting
for her to talk about whatever
spreadsheet she's working on than it is
for her to say and then I got this lunch
and then I got this coconut water and
then I went to the gym and then I had a
massage chair like those are the bits
that are interesting so there is a
little bit of selection bias going on
here but it seems to me that these tech
companies have got tons and tons of tons
of bloat they've gotten rid of that
given the fact that the stock market is
squeezing them and profits are going to
be down so they've just had to do Mass
layoffs now 12 000 people is so many
people
so if you remember when these tech
companies started blowing up they became
the subversive business successful
business we're not going to have
um a massive floor of cubicles lined up
we're going to have an open air thing we
don't you know
we we need creative thinkers I think
like Google had like a group of people
that they called like the dreamers or
something and they it was this really
cool kind of like futuristic ideal
um that became kind of cringy at a point
and I think we're catching the tail end
of that I think honest to God they're
like oh wait let's just uh you know bend
down the hatches here and like become an
actual business cut you know trim the
fat it sucks it definitely sucks um that
you know the the Millennials maybe even
later the Gen Z generation is dealing
with these layoffs whoever's there and
it could be older people or whatever but
I just remember this there were a ton of
movies like even when I think about like
the Elizabeth Holmes documentary at
theranos a lot of what they talked about
were these tech companies just like
just being very showy in their physical
space and that was with the the amount
of employees that they had these massive
campuses with butterfly rooms and Candy
rooms and we're different and things
like that
um when now they just
they just need to be a business you know
and I think that that's ultimately like
I think Elon and again I don't want to
like take a particular side in this but
I'm pretty sure Elon never ran Tesla
like that and uh so then when he went to
Twitter and he kind of saw that same
view of what of this like Playland for
work he was like all right let's just
stop doing this and let's dial it in a
little bit yes well I think
one of the reasons that you can afford
to have so much bloat is that the
margins that these companies have yes
are insane the reason that you can have
this massive campus and everyone gets
free lunch and there's a massage chair
is because these companies make tons and
tons of money hand over first because
their costs the cost of putting
something on the Internet apart from the
Manpower made to create it and the
service space to host it is essentially
zero and it's scalable it's unlimitedly
scalable it's it's the explosion and
then the ketchup right and we are at the
ketchup now like
um the explosion was like oh my God we
got so much money we'll just do whatever
it doesn't matter everything is caught
up now there might be saturation in the
market there might be competitors that
are coming to take you down the stock
market could suck uh and then you're
like okay now everything's caught up
like let's figure this out again
um it was a fun time but it was it was
interesting Yeah Austin that's got
didn't Facebook try and start build a
new business here or build a new
building here and they've just bailed
out part way through I just don't think
that they're going to use it or is it
Google maybe
um I I'm not sure I'm not sure that
they've built like a big campus um I
know there's a big apple
here a lot of big tech companies but I
didn't know if there was a big like plan
for some like massive amount of acreage
for a big meta campus coming here okay
so getting on to something that's very
very important calling a man bold counts
as sexual harassment UK judge rules UK
important tribunal argued that the use
of the word bald as an insult related to
a protected characteristic of sex
calling him on bulk and now because the
sexual harassment UK employment tribunal
judge has ruled this is CNBC three
members of the tribunal who decided on
the ruling and alluded to their own
experience of hair loss said that
baldness was more prevalent in men than
women therefore they are argued that the
use of the word bald as an insult
related to a protected characteristic of
sex the tribunal compared calling a man
bold to commenting on the size of a
woman's breasts based on a 1995 case
what do you think is is calling a man
ball the same you're a small titty [__]
you a small teddy [__]
and it's not it's just you bald
what if they have big titties then is
that the same yeah so small titties
claiming talking about a number another
woman's breasts is the same as talking
about a man's baldness what if I say
that you've got a beautiful head of hair
you've got a big head of hair that's a
lot of hair you've got there yeah uh wow
stop sexualizing me if if we were to
consider this versus The grammarly Thing
I wonder which one's more ridiculous
this is pretty this is pretty ridiculous
this isn't yeah this is pretty pretty
story the story is really good the
ruling published Wednesday was made on a
case where the insult was alleged to
have been used against Tony Finn while
he worked as an electrician for the
British bone Manufacturing Company Finn
had worked at the company who
manufactures wooden Cask closures for
the Brewing industry in Yorkshire in the
northeast of England for nearly 24 years
it was fired last year and the
circumstances around his dismissal were
also part of the case Finn claimed that
he was called a bald
and was also threatened
Jamie King in a dispute in July 2019 the
tribunal determined that using this
insult was a violation against the
claimant's dignity it creates an
intimidating environment it was done for
that purpose and it related to The
Climate sex so
ladies and gentlemen do not call a man
bald or you will get serious trouble I
mean the the
I didn't know that's why he filed it I
mean that that's just like you're making
fun of someone on the job that's
harassment right uh I don't think saying
the word bald as a description should be
then uh
you know more specifically like tuned
into oh this is sexual harassment like
the bald part saying someone's a bald
like that's just making fun of someone
right like that's harassment of course
on the job
um
what that's that's what they said but
the problem the problem is that if you
want to do protected sex characteristics
you're going to open up these kinds of
conversations right because on average
women don't go bold that much so it
means that men will take their boldness
as a protected characteristic it's the
same reason why oh so now we're
factoring averages and generalizations I
think so but I don't think we I don't
think people want to do that that often
do they I saw a really interesting post
on Instagram yesterday about the fact
that calling someone uh an incel or a
virgin or a cook online is significantly
more accepted than [__] shaming if you
were to call a girl on social media a
[__] or a [__] that would go down very
badly but if you were to accuse a guy of
being a virgin that would just be seen
as a a quippy insult so there are
asymmetries in what is typically used
and what's typically accepted I think
and uh yeah bald lives matter man but in
think in a world where we're not allowed
to make rules based off of
generalizations right where we have to
factor in every little specific thing
you're now making a rule based off of a
generalization what's an example that
we're not allowed to make something
based on generalization well we have to
factor in all different genders and and
Norms like we we create rules based off
of
you know uh transgenders wanting to use
different bathrooms things like that who
are this they're not
the nor they are not uh a major piece
they're they're not um they're an outlet
they're an outlier where now we're using
a general out you know a generality to
determine this rule right like men are
bald women aren't so now we have to make
this rule
it's very interesting
I I I actually think that this is
part of a just general odd trend of
people getting themselves into
situations in court where they just they
just want to get back at somebody that
they feel has aggrieved them and now
without actually realizing it you have
somehow created a precedent where
calling a man bald counts as sexual
harassment in the UK because it's a
protected sex characteristic I Americans
see things that the UK
do and we just laugh like we think it's
hilarious and the funny thing is the
opposite happens too the UK sees things
that America does and they laugh too we
just laugh at each other for the stupid
[__] that we do the stupid rules that we
come up with
is so funny I I remember you said this
to me yesterday man and I just I was
laughing so hard because it was in the
UK that's why I thought it was funny and
that for no real reason it's just like
it'll be coming for the U.S as well yeah
did you see that Floyd Mayweather is
stepping back into the ring I mean I I
didn't see that but it's like
it's kind of weird that guy his uh it's
it's the old uh well if I can make a
bunch of money off of this like am I
Really Gonna retire yeah just not his
thing is not getting hit it's yes so
it's getting a big payday
mmafighting.com Floyd Mayweather books
next exhibition bout against ex Bellator
fighter reality TV star Aaron Chalmers
so I used to party with Aaron Chalmers
in Newcastle back in the day Aaron
Chalmers became famous for being on
Geordie Shore which is oh so he's a
majority yeah okay British equivalent of
Jersey Shore
and he then pivoted from reality TV to
MMA he had a two and two professional
record and then he retired two years ago
so a non-boxer I think he maybe did do
one one boxing fight perhaps but anyway
he uh he
is not exactly an elite opponent hasn't
been in the ring for two years uh on
Monday Mayweather announced that he'll
be facing ex Bellator fighter and
reality TV star Aaron Chalmers on
February 25th so that's only one month's
time what
pounds does it say uh I don't think so
these um whatever they're called
exhibition fights really seem to be kind
of fast and loose with all of this
since retiring with the perfect perfect
15-0 record this final win coming over
the two division UFC champion Conor
McGregor maywether has stayed busy with
a long string of exhibition bats
remembering he only fought deji what
four months ago three months ago he's
faced mixed martial artists social
influences and over-matched boxes while
continuing to Pat his fortune with what
is likely a hefty payday every time he
competes he initially announced a fight
against one Championship white high
fighter Liam Harrison who is coached by
a friend of mine however that matchup
fell apart as quickly as it came
together because Harrison's under
contract Chalmers stepped in a man who
hasn't been in the ring for two years
and his reality TV star uh and the only
thing that I can think is that
Mayweather absolutely desperately needs
the money
yeah which is really strange right
because I I remember some article saying
he was one of the richest athletes on
the planet at some point best paid
best paid okay so not best managed well
not best money managed correct not least
expending yeah wow okay uh first off
who's watching that fight
like are we gonna be like oh man the the
Floyd Mayweather Geordie Shore guy and
fight is is going to be on
you know what I mean like
like well we gotta head out we gotta go
to the bar on Sixth we gotta go we gotta
go I'll wait to see Geordie Show versus
Floyd Mayweather well here's another
question like why wouldn't it be why not
fight Jake Paul why not flight KSI those
would both be you thought ksi's worst
boxing younger brother yeah and you've
fought Logan Paul that is the brother of
here's a better question why not just
manage your money better why not stop
spending it all yeah yeah have you seen
let's see if his Instagram is still the
same because it used to be the case back
in the day
Floyd Mayweather's Instagram was
basically endless adverts for a strip
club yes is it still that
valuable people don't pay for the thing
uh maybe it's not maybe it's not quite
as bad
ah no it doesn't look as quite as
degenerate as it used to would you
remember what do you remember the ones I
mean it was just right but that's his
business adverts it's his business it's
probably good business titties are
always good business well yeah but I
mean come on mate like you're a boxer
you've got however many million
followers you've got yeah right we're
talking about a guy who's made maybe a
billion dollars
point six million followers posting out
titties to everybody and this post's got
somebody's got to do it 2 000 comments
yeah I um I just think it what it shows
is not only does he need the money but
he needs the money now because if he
needed the most money he would be able
to wait around for contract negotiations
with the KSI or a Jake Paul and it would
end up being a much more attractive I
would watch Jake Paul versus Mayweather
I would go to Sixth Street and find
somewhere with you and we would sit down
and we would get tacos and we would
watch that fight so I'd be interested in
what happened yes I have no interest in
this so what that means is oh well I was
a big follower of Geordie Shore so I
can't say it say the same man
sorry I know the first [__] time I've
ever heard of this show
you're a massive I am aware that you're
a massive fan when it comes to that
um but yeah I I just think that it's
evident that he really really needs the
money very very good do you ever think
do you ever think that some of these uh
some of these athletes are like junkies
for what they do like it's all they know
for the their entire lives and then they
get out and they're like wow I don't
want to be out
yeah I mean maybe maybe junkie is a
little harsh maybe it's not him Chunky's
a little harsh but it could be the case
I don't know
what was that thing that you were
telling me about to do with the new
supplement law
oh I don't know enough about it we can't
I I don't know enough
um I took a couple of notes down for
people that are interested so Senator
Richard Durbin is trying to pass a bill
we got we go back we call him Dick
Durbin yeah Dick Durbin this is an
Illinois Senator bro this is you know
how how famous is this he's got a
he's got an existing nickname
so that no like uh Richard is that's the
nickname for Richard yeah but like yeah
we call him well that's it yeah because
in when he ran I mean it's much like
vote for Dick Durbin Dick Durbin yeah
I'll just say that Illinois and Chicago
some of the most corrupt politicians and
politics to have ever existed in America
so we stand by that yeah so he's trying
to process bill which is Bill s 40 90.
it would add a regulation which wouldn't
allow any supplement to be sold without
meeting expensive regulation criteria
um and the question from the video that
I had sent you was
um what does he have to gain from this
is he invested in some pharmaceutical
companies right can you explain for the
people that don't understand can you
explain what the process is for getting
a supplement out into the world at the
moment as far as I'm concerned there
really is not much that needs to be done
like almost at all I'm pretty sure
um
I don't know if you have to register
with the FDA even
um and because there is an FDA bylaw I
remember looking into this at some point
um where like they don't have the right
to uh like basically audit your product
and make sure that you're selling
whatever you're selling so yeah this law
seems pretty pretty good well that's the
thing I mean it seems pretty good but
I'll say this who stands to win and it's
that's why I dislike it I was I was
leaning towards let's not do this
um we talked extensively about how Tick
Tock is making children's brains into
gray matter okay that's much more scary
than some bodybuilder selling some you
know sketchy uh supplement products to a
small amount of people when you know I I
personally don't like seeing
pharmaceutical pharmaceutical companies
and and big companies winning especially
when a small business can do it the
right way we know people who own small
supplement business and they take a lot
of pride in the product that they make
they would not be able to sell these
products they would not be able to have
a business if this thing went through
and that's what I'm concerned with so
I'm leaning towards saying [__] Dick
Durbin uh on this one [__] dick [__]
dick on this I I I thought but I mean
it's interesting to think about both
sides right like yeah regulation could
be kind of cool because you could be
consuming poison well I said when you
brought it up to me this morning before
we went to the gym as you swallowed down
two scoops of completely untested random
powder mixed in water you and Dylan are
just having this proprietary blend and
like horse hair and bull semen and
whatever it is like how toes and stuff
and that's what you that's what you're
taking that being said
um you guys in the bodybuilding
community large generally has a
soft spot for
a guy with a large bathtub and a ton of
meth and he sprinkles a bit of the meth
into a pre-workout and then you get to
use it this is Jack 3D this is what's
that what's the labs that makes crack
oh so that yeah so crack is not even
that has uh
dimethyl or something it's dmaa is what
we call it dmaa that's what that's what
was in the old Jack 3D formula uh and
that is a banned substance now 15 years
later re-released yes but you have to
buy it on eBay basically yeah um look we
have a soft spot right for that because
it's like fun you know and we're
responsible like we we know one of the
guys who I think is like the top
mind around supplements in Derrick yeah
and like we are responsible consumers
obviously teenage kids uh who go and get
sketchy internet drugged so that they
can work out harder that's not a good
thing you know right so I mean look at
uh Logan Paul's Prime man that's got 200
milligrams of caffeine and it's being
drank by 11 year olds it's being drank
by kids that weigh one third of your
body size yeah that's the Wild Thing
This is and I'm gonna go on a bit of a
tangent here okay because I do think
there is a caffeine consumption uh like
epidemic in America
um I remember asking this woman what she
drank this morning she said I had a
venti cold bro which is uh venti cold
brew and I like looked it up as
something like 250 milligrams caffeine
she's 125 pounds okay she's like yeah
I'll probably get another calf or
probably get another coffee
um at 3 P.M now there is some science
that talks about athletic performance
around uh caffeine use and it could be
anywhere from I mean there is clinical
dosage of like actual improvements in
athletic performance it's three to
sometimes even nine 10 milligrams per
kilogram of body weight so being a
hundred kilo male you can take 300 to
almost 900 milligrams and it sounds
crazy right but we're talking about
athletic performance here we're not
talking about a buzz so you can go to
your marketing job Susie okay so we have
there's absolutely a caffeine degeneracy
and I definitely feed into it okay I
totally understand that but uh it's it's
something that that definitely needs to
be talked about but I what something I
want to say is Red Bull was the of like
was the first like okay let's get
caffeine remember that and people used
to hate Red Bull for that reason and
then there was Red Bull vodkas which
started to happen I remember it was all
over the news saying don't drink Red
Bull vodkas it's an upper and a downer
it's killing you all this [__] right now
we have drinks I don't know how much is
in a Red Bull eighty a hundred uh one
the small camp the small can yeah maybe
one twenty one fifty I think it's 150.
that's nothing bro that's a walk in the
[__] Park especially for Susie she's
gotta have two of those okay so it just
the line just keeps changing another
thing too man the um
what's the martini espresso martini
okay we used to complain about uh Red
Bull vodkas and now people are obsessed
with espresso martinis hey you're
doubling the [__] Red Bull vodka
sweetheart you think you're being all
cutesy because it's in a different class
that's just caffeine and straight
alcohol going right into you
okay
[Laughter]
that's my rant and I'm sticking with it
I gotta talk about this it's intake it's
a fair take man but I think when it
comes to the the supplement thing
the concern that you would have from
everybody's side that doesn't want
legislation is if the only way that
companies can make stuff like a
multivitamin or a greens powder or a
creatine or whatever is to go through
this very expensive process you're then
going to raise up the price because that
needs to be passed down to the consumer
these companies aren't going to make
products for nothing so first off you
push a ton of small companies out which
reduces competition which means that
companies can then that remain in the
market can then charge more they can
also need to charge more because of the
increased cost they've had to go through
in order to get this pop product
regulated
and that means that the customers end up
paying more that being said are there
concerns I have pretty big concerns
about the fact that you can me and you
can go out to the garden and just
create a random list of ingredients and
go now it's a supplement hide it behind
proprietary blend yeah and it's just
this pixie dust thing and we can create
a Cool brand and start selling it of
course that that that is a concern uh
and I don't really know what the
solution is neither of those worlds seem
particularly great to me yeah I'm I'm I
agree with you I agree with you even
though it seems as though I'm like
staunchly on one side I totally agree
with you I I do think though I'm leaning
uh away from the regulation
I would agree I don't think that I'm
down for regulation longer term
um what else we got here
that gym girl a gym that Jessica gym
girl the lady who who did The Tick Tock
thing obviously recounted a horrific
experience that she went through in the
gym uh as she did hip thrusts and a guy
glanced her way three or four times
during a three minute long set she got
quite upset about it and now she's had
to release a twit longer talking about
how Tick Tock creator has issued an
effusive what's effusive
pleasure or approval in an unrestrained
or heartfelt manner I don't think that
that was the tone of her public apology
yeah I don't think she said that word no
Fernandez was hit with a torrent of
abuse over a video she posted last week
in which she fumed a fellow weightlifter
was staring at her like a piece of meat
and she did say that she also said this
is why I don't want to have children
this is why we need to like I should go
over and pull his pee pee off uh manipa
it was just every different
headline like quote e headline that you
would get in a tick tock video was put
into one
um we also watched from an unnamed gym
in Austin Texas a video that started off
with a guy pretending like he was going
to teach you how to approach girls in
the gym and it's a dude with his top off
and he's in good condition and he says
I'm going to teach you how to approach
girls in the gym and then it pans to a
group of six or seven girls next to him
and they just say
don't
and flick the hair and walk away total
girl boss moment a serious Guild boss
moment
I don't know about you but if I'm into
the gym and I'm single and I'm trying to
find a girl that I like dating in the
gym is a really really like finding
Partners in the gym is a really good
place to start you know that you've got
tons in common you know that you are
probably going to have a fitness journey
that you could go on together
it it seems to me that reducing the
likelihood that men not only outside of
the gym because it'll cross over but in
the gym will approach a girl that they
like who both may be single and maybe
the girl was looking at him and thinking
wow like he's quite nice
are there situations during which girls
feel uncomfortable in the gym yes does
this Jessica doing her hip thrusts at 60
pounds
class is one of those no she doesn't and
yeah so I have the the post right here
this guy kept making me feel extremely
comfortable uncomfortable at my gym this
is why I'll end up crying on stream
because I feel so grossed out at times
with the amount of sexualization I
experience hopefully this spreads
awareness for girls who experience this
type of treatment at the gym and then on
the next slide so this is by a meme
account called the gains
um did great research on this
um but in the next slide it's the it
shows her um
uh her page she's a content creator and
oh there's a link tree and in that link
tree there is an only fans so look I
don't want to say I don't want to say
this
um because that would be way too far of
a leap that if you are on if you haven't
only fans you deserve to get sexualized
everywhere but it's it it does seem a
little bit odd that you're complaining
about the sexualization of yourself when
that's exactly what you're commodifying
right um and and uh the the actual video
herself the guy was just like he would
like look over that was it it was like
five seconds he asked if he could help
her to put the weights on but I mean
this is this particular story yeah
heavily heavily heavily done to death
but quite well and I think that
situations like this uh important to
remind people about boundaries
and you know her groveling apology that
she's come out and spoken about how she
didn't realize that this is damaging and
she reflected after the thousands of
comments that she received etc etc I
think that
very few people would look at that video
and say the guy did anything wrong
almost everybody would look at it and
say the girl was out of order and the
response is important because it teaches
both guys and girls what is appropriate
behavior if you want guys to walk around
a gym being I've thought this before
especially some of the gyms that we've
trained at in Austin there's girls
everywhere right and I'm like I can't
there's nowhere really for me to look
apart from looking at you that doesn't
have a girl within my field of view yeah
so
you can imagine if you're a young
impressionable guy that you could
actually get yourself into this stage
where the toxic male gaze is something
you're so terrified of that you you
actually become super self-conscious
maybe you're really unhappy with you you
feel like you're you've inherited some
flaw some sort of gender sex-based flaw
that you can't get rid of you're this
unsalvageable insufficient awful human
that's not very good and then also for
girls in the gym
this reminds because girls will uh that
all of our preferences get influenced by
the people that are around us
if other girls start to see that let's
say that the response to that video was
yeah [__] that guy that's completely out
of order that guy totally shouldn't be
doing that that will begin to set the
new boundary for what girls deem in the
gym to be acceptable and unacceptable
behavior and if you make acceptable
behavior massively unacceptable that
basically conditions goals to feel much
more vulnerable all the time they're
going to become more upset at things
that maybe aren't worth them becoming
upsetter this is how concept creep
happens right if if everything is racist
then nothing is racist right yes and
over time you start to expand the
definition of racism to encapsulate
anything that you can but the problem
that nobody ever talks about is the fact
that for the people who experience both
real and non-real racism that makes
their lives worse
the people that experience real
harassment in the gym which was not this
girl now feel like they're being lumped
in with somebody that experienced
something way less traumatic and for the
people who aren't experiencing sexual
objectification they're now wondering
well maybe that maybe that little glance
that that guy did through the door as we
walk through maybe that is something
that I should be concerned about and
this is how people become ever more
anxious in situations because of this
concept group and that that anxiety goes
away
um over the internet and so I think uh
the the physical picking up of women or
vice versa is definitely dying down a
little bit especially if there's a fear
uh to looking like a creep and being
caught on video for it
um but you you had talked about just in
general
talking to women or other people in the
gym
and um what was you said this this is
kind of the the red pill definition
thing is like the difference between a
creep and what what is it it's like the
difference between someone you creeped
out by and someone that you are happy
came up to you is how attracted you are
to them right which is not entirely true
but that's a very that's a very like red
pill it's not entirely false though
either right true even a girl that's in
a relationship if if some absolute hunk
if Chris Hemsworth comes over to her uh
she
is less likely to feel insulted at the
very least
right and um you know it could actually
feel good for her or whatever whatever
yeah yeah and I I think
the main thing that I would ever suggest
to someone is to just try and have some
self-awareness and to go along the lines
of like friendship first and see what
happens
right I mean I think that in general
like there is a place I guess for pickup
Artistry but it's much narrower than
just meeting and talking to people
um and you're gonna I feel like you're
gonna have a higher likelihood of being
successful uh with a potential mate if
uh if you go that route if you go the
route of just talking first and and
establishing some sort of base level
connection well being casual is always
going to come off more cool right yeah I
think the main mediator
is whether or not girls feel safe I
think that their concern you know if
Chris Hemsworth came up um was sorry I I
just wanted to say that I think you look
really nice today and I hope that you're
having a great workout and then he
wanders off or whatever right or what's
your name whatever the lame opening line
is that you decide to use
whether that was Chris Hemsworth or some
other guy the bigger difference is going
to be if this dude comes up and starts
being very very forthcoming uh yes close
body language but that doesn't work no
matter what I think true but even if
even Chris Hemsworth couldn't get away
with that is my point right it doesn't
matter how good looking that that guy is
if he comes over and he overlays that
aggressiveness you're going to begin to
really really select out there will be a
cohort of women that are attracted to
that very forthcoming type guy but it's
going to be significantly tuned down and
the worry that most girls have about
guys coming up to them in the gym I
think is that it's not you know it it
must be flattering for a girl to have a
guy come over and pay her a compliment
do you want to go through the rest of
your life never receiving compliments
that are well-meaning and not
objectifying and all the rest of it
is that a world that you really want to
live in if you're a girl that works hard
in the gym and a guy never comes up to
you and says that you actually look nice
that would suck yeah I don't know yeah
it depends I don't know what the result
of this would be
I don't know well I mean we're not girls
and we don't often receive compliments
the only compliments that guys receive
in the gym are from other guys I think
in
15 or 16 years of training in the gym
I've never received a compliment from a
girl in the gym uh
I can't remember I literally can't
remember have you ever received maybe
with weightlifting you would get that
kind of like good lift yeah good lift
type of thing but
I don't know
um
maybe I like I like your shirt
yeah yeah something like that or like
the lowest yeah something like that
anyway what have you got coming up next
man what can people expect from you over
the next month or so
um just some new uh style of content
that I've been doing with our friend our
mutual friend Dylan
um it's kind of what we've decided to do
was
sometimes just lifting content online
and most of the time lifting content
online can get kind of boring
um other times podcasting content online
can get kind of boring so what we've
done is kind of Miss mixed the two if
you're ever bored with the way that the
conversation is going just hold out you
can watch us do some snatching and clean
a jerking and like fun uh you know
weightlifting style movements and things
like that
um and if you get bored of that we might
be talking about valuable things like it
doesn't matter
um you were even on the episode today
and and I'm really excited about the
potential for that these shorter clips
that we've been posting on Instagram
have been doing really well and I'm
hoping that it can kind of draw people
to the longer style people have been
asking for it like we would love to see
a podcast like this this is a great idea
you did Matt Fraser as well there's a
map forever episode yeah
that was honest to God that episode was
like why I started a podcast I felt that
uh when I met Matt Fraser him and I were
like Kindred Spirits we both uh went to
University of Vermont at the same time
we both think the same way around
training and we both started in
weightlifting but then after that
conversation I felt this emotional
connection to the guy that I didn't
think I would I would have had before
and I like upon reflecting I'm like damn
this is really what podcasting is all
about like don't you feel the same way
like sometimes you you get done with
that episode and you're like man that
was a good episode really great but
other times you get done with someone
and you're like holy [__] I just made
like a a bond
you know and uh I'm so blessed to be
able to share that experience now it was
something that I was nervous you and I
had talked a lot about should I do a
podcast should I not and I did it and um
I'm loving it and you know something
with this training style of podcast
where we're lifting I want to bring
people on like I want to bring people
that you know go to the gym casually and
and lift with them and like shoot the
[__] I think it could be a really great
idea so that's really all I have going
on um anyone who wants to check me out
go to Zach telling or
z-a-c-k-t-e-l-a-n-d-e-r on uh YouTube
and you can also check me out on
Instagram uh coach underscore ZT and
then if you want to start training you
can go to my patreon patreon.com
that's it dude I appreciate you thank
you thank you what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]